last night's the fake news media was all
up in arms trying to shade Michael Cohen
the personal lawyer to Donald Trump who
has clients like Sean Hannity and
technically me I keep him on a retainer
until his teeth are straight I love the
guy he's perfect he's what would happen
if entourage and The Sopranos did a
crossover episode but not my boy Mikey
is being smeared just for making an
honest but for making a buck Michael
Cohen cashed in by selling his access to
the President to secure very lucrative
consulting deals but raises ethical
questions drug maker Novartis admits
they pay going more than a million
dollars after Cohen offered access one
source describing Cohen's sales pitch as
quote I don't know who's been
representing you but you should fire
them all I'm the guy you should hire I'm
closest to the president I'm his
personal lawyer oh yes you know it's
like they say keep your friends close
and your lawyer closer so then he can
sell that closeness to the highest
bidder
Cohen is the real deal he's not some
elitist who went to the best college he
went to the opposite of that
Thomas M cooley Law School which lawyer
snobs called the worst law school in
America good fine that's good that's
good that's good that's a plus that's
all his not learning law time was spent
acquiring other talents which just makes
other lawyers like stormy Daniels's
court beefcake Michael avenatti so so
jelly he was selling access to the
highest office in the land doing things
that he is completely unqualified to do
now we hear from Novartis that he was
hired on healthcare matters evidently
he's a doctor one of the companies
mentioned they hired him for real estate
matters he's a real estate agent another
company stated that they hired him for
accounting advice evidently he's an
accountant so he's a lawyer a doctor and
accountant in a real estate agent what
would with that what's with
i buy that combo no one questions when a
restaurant is a Pizza Hut and a Taco
Bell you give it a Michelin star and you
move on and of course a health care
company paid Michael Cohen 1.2 million
dollars the guy knows human anatomy like
when he said if you do something wrong
I'm going to come at you grab you by the
neck and I'm not going to let you go
until I'm finished that's doctor talk
they don't teach strangulation until the
third year of med school to the left
they want to paint Michael Cohen as some
kind of swamp filling Russian friending
hush-money pain bad guy who's not
qualified to teach high school
volleyball but they're focused on the
wrong Michael the real bad guy here is
Michael Abba naughty emphasis on the
naughty the hysterical left is obsessed
with the wrong part of the story the
substance the details but they're not
paying attention to the important part
the messenger I can't stand this tight
sure empanada clown and I can't escape
it he's on all day every day as a fact
in the last 48 hours
he's been on nine different shows this
guy's got a toothbrush at CNN a cot at
MSNBC and a locker at Riverdale but of
course this Air Force one chaser even
has a response to that criticism there's
been some criticism about how our media
strategy and how often I'm on CNN and
how often I've been on your show and
other networks etc okay it's all a bunch
of nonsense because here's the bottom
line Anderson it's working okay it's
working in spades spades racist not
going to
offensive offensive shameful I will say
this he is right his strategy is working
Abba Noddy is running the court but two
can play at the TV lawyer game Trump has
his own attorney who's been all over the
news this week Rudy Giuliani he may not
be as slick but he's bold he's raw
dancing through arguments like a sack of
marbles falling down a flight of stairs
so the President did know about this
after the campaign those are the facts
that we're still working on and that you
know maybe in a little bit of dispute
this is more rumor than it is anything
else well that's what you said that to
BuzzFeed but here's the well yeah I mean
that's that's one of the possibilities
and one of the rings you stated it is
fact well maybe I did I could prove it
but I can't throw this back oh oh whoa
and that's that's only a fraction of his
argument the rest was mostly Rudy
calling Donald Trump his special friend
and reminding people how many porn shops
used to be in Times Square so why is
everyone lauding avenatti but attacking
Rudy it's obviously not because avenatti
brings an endless stream of damaging
information about the president and Rudy
sounds like a Halloween store skeleton
running out of batteries that would make
sense that doesn't make sense
no TV is all about one thing sex appeal
Michael avenatti I know what you're
thinking you're thinking I know that
handsome lawyer the very cute Michael
avenatti is here
very cute yes very cute
[Applause]
what is TV anymore phases if you're
getting Jason Biggs that riled up then
you're either a sexy lawyer or a warm
pastry look of course rudy is gonna
struggle he knows that naughty avenatti
the hottie with the body Esquire is out
there beating him like a drum made out
of a dead horse well I'm not letting
Evan addy dominate the shallow image
focus mainstream media one more day so
I'm stepping in if Trump's gonna beat
Evan Adi back to where he came from
presumably some commercial shoot for
Greek yogurt the president's going to
need a new lawyer specifically a hot
lawyer ladies and gentlemen please
welcome the opposition's new
presidential advocate hot lawyer Michael
Gucci Gucci
[Applause]
[Music]
Michael goochy goochy Esquire
welcome to the show you are an
experienced hot lawyer right order in
the court jordan checks out so I'll tell
you that's that's the body I want the
president's truth coming out of right
there you know what let me give you a
few talking points that I have sketched
out counselor goochy goochy did the
president know anything about a Russian
oligarch pain Michael Cohen half a
million dollars no the only thing the
president knows about business is
winning man this lawyer is hot I didn't
write that I did write that yes no sorry
let's keep going
hot lawyer Gucci Gucci should the
president testify no even though he does
have a strong case
convincing subtle and you don't mind I'm
just going to spritz you lightly pretty
Gucci
his rod Rosen Steve let the Muller
investigation get totally out of hands
the Deputy Attorney General has allowed
the investigation stray from its
original mandate and pursuant to article
2 section 4 of the United States
Constitution
Rosen Stein should be impeached
yeah well that's how you hot lawyer it
up
hey cable news if you want goochy goochy
to debate avenatti he's ready anytime
anywhere go to our hot lawyer dot-com
for booklet info I also do bachelorette
parties yeah our lawyer Michael Gucci
Gucci
[Music]